it should cost a billion to look this
good Beyonce sang that on pure honey
from her 2022 album Renaissance and
given the Stellar year the 42-year-old
Entertainer has had money doesn't appear
to be a problem Forbes estimates she is
now on a Glide path to becoming a
billionaire with a net worth of $800
million in June Beyonce ranked number 48
on forbes's annual list of the richest
self-made women in America with a net
worth of 540 million
the dramatic boost of her Fortune could
be attributed to her substantial 2023
earnings she banked an estimated $100
million post tax from the Renaissance
World Tour as well as an adjustment to
Forbes estimate of her music catalog and
her art collection sources tell Forbes
the singer's catalog is now worth some
$300 million the remainder of her net
worth is made up of the personal assets
she shares with her billionaire husband
Jay-Z as well as her business Holdings
through parkw entertainment which she
found founded in
2010 one of the major drivers to the
increase to Beyonce's net worth was her
Blockbuster Renaissance tour which ran
from May to October and spanned 39
cities in 17 countries Renaissance
brought in more than 579 million in
Revenue making it one of the top 10
highest grossing tours in history
according to billboard for Renaissance a
filmed by Beyonce the movie based on the
concert tour she reportedly struck a
similar deal with AMC theaters that
Taylor Swift did for her erist Tor movie
for going Studio participation Beyonce
released the film which she also wrote
produced and directed through AMC
meaning she will split the revenue
directly Renaissance gross 27.4 million
worldwide in its opening weekend earning
the number one spot at the domestic box
office beyond music and fashion beyon
shares an extensive real estate
portfolio with Jay-Z which is worth some
$320 million
including a $200 million Malibu mansion
the couple purchased in June which is
believed to be the most expensive home
in California history Forbes allocates
half the total of their shared real
estate as well as half the value of
their extensive art collection to each
Entertainer representatives for Beyonce
did not respond to Forbes request for
comment